david do you think political beliefs
should be a protected class
like religion national origin ethnicity
and race
this is a really good question my
general
view for a long time has been things
that are personal choices
shouldn't be protected classes there
should be
the possibility of consequences for the
choices that you make
now this is very easy when it comes to
some people don't choose their race
people don't choose their ethnicity
people don't choose their sexual
orientation
people don't choose their nationality
where they were born people don't choose
for example to have a physical
disability
these are things that are beyond our our
control and we off
typically we also can't control that
they are visible to others now you might
say well nationality is not really
visible just by looking at someone
well but maybe okay there are cases
where it's not
but it's certainly not self-professed i
can't say i'm norwegian and now i'm
norwegian
um so so uh that i think is
is an important thing what are sort of
inborn
characteristics or things beyond our
control versus
things that are that are really just
choices now that puts religion outside
of protected class i understand that
religion is a protected class
both membership in or lack of membership
in religion
that is a protected class in the united
states by this self-professed
standpoint religion would be outside of
it and that would be antithetical to
what many think the united states is
about now
on the other hand sexual orientation in
many states
still isn't a protected class i believe
that
it should be political beliefs not
currently
a protected class other than in
washington dc
so you can discriminate against people
based on their political beliefs
in florida you could say we don't allow
democrats in this place and that would
be
legal um there is a way in which
political beliefs are protected which is
the first amendment
um and the the government cannot
punish you or abridge your ability to
speak
about what your political views are but
uh that doesn't mean there aren't
consequences to your political beliefs
if you decide to sort of
state them now there are complexities
with political beliefs in terms of a
protected class because
political beliefs are so broad and i'll
give you some examples
if i say as an example
the treasury of the united states
is a uh terrible institution
and it's a scam or so you know whatever
that's a political belief and people
might disagree but like the consequences
of that or the possibility of my belief
about the treasury having consequences
it's sort of more abstract and difficult
to imagine like it's hard to imagine
somebody getting fired because of their
view
about the treasury unless maybe they
work for the treasury okay fair
on the other hand you could argue that
someone has a political belief
that um you know uh that it should be
legal
uh to that i don't even know that jewish
people and black people
shouldn't be allowed to hold public
office okay imagine imagine that
um that also is a political belief
which many of us would imagine would
realistically have consequences with an
employer as an example an employer finds
out
well we have black people and jewish
people who who work here
and that's something we we just that's
bad for
for what's going on here and so that's a
political belief which
we believe should get someone fired we
don't want somebody working with that if
you pull
if you protect political beliefs as a
protected class
would an employer no longer be able to
fire someone for something like that
i think it's very very difficult
extraordinarily difficult
my view is i don't believe political
beliefs should be a protected class
i think to the extent that um
political beliefs are protected by the
first amendment
uh that's fine and that's sufficient
but i can't think of a reason to add
political beliefs as a protected class
you can also just shut up if you're in
an environment where your political
beliefs may be problematic you can shut
up
if you're black there's no way you can
say oh in this environment
i will prevent people from knowing i'm
black if you
have a physical disability that puts you
in a wheelchair
you can't say that might be seen
negatively in this context
so i will just hide the fact that i'm in
a wheelchair from people
you can't do it so so my view is
do not list political beliefs as a
protected class i think religious
beliefs are a question mark but i
understand the historical reality
of religious belief and non-belief uh as
protected in the united states so i'm
not
advocating for its removal from a
protected class
let me know your thoughts on this i
think that the the the broadness
of political belief is what makes this
quite
quite complicated we've got a great
bonus show for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
you